[Music]
good burp thank you for sharing welcome
back to the Jenna Jillian bunny pod now
you are a guest last week you sat in the
podcast chair last week right this
episode's brought to you by the skin
guys get in the know what the skin is a
newsletter that comes in to your email
inbox completely for free to update you
and inform you on the most important
things going on the world just go to the
skin th es ki mm that's two M's com /
annejulien it's completely free get
started and when you enter and subscribe
with your email you entered one
individual or Visa gift card to spend
wherever you want also guys stitch fix
imagine having your own personal online
stylist that could be you okay they
curate clothes just for you just for
your style and it's delivered right to
your door no pressure to go shopping not
that anyone can even go shopping right
now but stitch fix is a wonderful
wonderful product and they actually do
an incredible job of picking clothes
that you actually will want to keep and
we're also go to stitch fix STI tch Fi
XCOM slash Jenna Julian and you get an
extra 25% off when you keep everything
in your box also guys Squarespace if
you're building the website deal with
Squarespace even if it's just a fun
website for an event wedding a side
business a little hobby you have
whatever it is do a Squarespace it's a
drag and drop visit visual web site
builder that makes everything very easy
go to Squarespace comm / Jenna Julian
save 10% off your first purchase or
website or domain or go with the free
trial check it out Peggy sponsors what
is welcome this the chili cook-off they
cook-off I mean we're just gonna cook
some chili cook-off implies there's a
competition by chili
I mean we're missing tons of ingredients
this is Quarantine chili
quarantine and chill Lee yeah okay
am i right no you're wrong no ladies or
men so I just realized if you don't have
some water I need two cups of water and
I just went downstairs so we have
something so it's your turn for sure all
right then I guess I'll be going to get
some water so that'll be fun but Jenna
woke up today actually she woke up
yesterday and was like I want chili
Jenna gets this way about chili she
gives this way about Buffalo and she
gets this way about soup those are the
three foods that Jenna needs needs and
randomly needs like almost like they're
her medicine and she's like oh I'm low
on this I need it she has needs and this
morning like yesterday morning she was
like I want [ __ ] chili and we have a
good amount of food in our pantry food
like beans rice you know like the things
that you can hold for a while in your
pantry nuts flowers things like that so
can things so Jenna was like we don't
have any kidney beans so we were waiting
on our delivery of kidney beans source I
ordered him a month ago
yeah and they did not come when we were
waiting for them so anyway we got all
the ingredients again said my package is
lost how do y'all lose a bunch of bags
of beans dude I don't know I mean it's
crazy yeah those kidney beans I needed
my chili like a while ago alone so what
are we doing well I finally got another
order of kidney beans and I'm just so
ready to have chili this is all I can
think about today I was like can I cook
it on the podcast enjoy like yell grab
my hot plate I don't know if this is
like a good idea or we're gonna have to
carry this pot downstairs it really is
gonna be like Kevin's chili cook-off if
somebody trips Kevin's world-famous
chili here's what we'll do I'm gonna run
and get some water and while I do that
you can explain to people your why you
love chili and what's special about your
recipe I don't know talk about chili I'm
also going to remove the crying one from
here I leave them downstairs
you take TG I'm gonna take all the
littles they're being bad we thought we
could trust you guys in here but I don't
think this is safe to cook chili while
y'all walk around and scream underfoot
[Music]
Jellicoe golf yeah
you have peach peach ego peach you go
with that ego anyways so my favorite
type of chili I usually make with beyond
me
but not just the beef sometimes I use it
with the hot Italian sausage and it's so
good and I make a big pot and I prefer
like only kidney beans in my chili and a
lot of people use like pinto beans or
black beans but I just think the kidney
beans are the best part so I only put
kidney beans in my chili but we don't
really have beyond me I looked on Amazon
and this should go in for like $85 we
have some like stocked up in our freezer
but like not a lot and it's this I don't
know you can totally eat chili without
it like I think Julian would want like a
burger someday so hold on let me show
you what's in my pot so I have bowls and
spoons cuz we'll have a little taste in
when this is done yum and fun now I have
little boxes of kidney beans because
these are the only ones that were
available on Amazon for me to order to
my home everything else was sold out and
my package of dried red kidney beans got
lost in the mail so I don't know how
many means I want but I just brought
that many I got some cumin I got diced
tomatoes and crushed Tomatoes a can
opener so I can open these cans see I be
thinking what else is in here
chili powder this is the kind that our
neighbor recommended to us cuz she said
that's her face
right so I believe her and trust her
with my life and a little blue young
cube we don't have any begin boo-yan
cubes that are like beef flavored but I
think that'd be ideal nor do we have any
like stock so we're using a boo-yan cube
and some water and here we go you said
it's gonna get loud it's gonna make
noise not silent okay turn her on wait
this is fun are you having fun yeah
we're cooking on the podcast cook cast
god you cook I can't even see inside the
pot so how are we gonna get this
downstairs once it's like all hot you
have to let it cool here no I just
I'll go get my gloves my hot gloves I'm
scared okay that's fine that's normal
that's enough okay what else we need so
I'm gonna be using a little bit of olive
oil because we don't have like a meat or
a meat substitute to give us some fat to
cook with because I usually wouldn't
like put any oil and chili because you
don't need it and got garlic and these
peppers our neighbor gave to us from her
garden and they are spicy spicy boys
because why have some puss-ass chili no
I agree I think chili should always be
packing heat and in this boy right here
I have a mixture of salt black pepper
and my literal favorite which is sugar
if you put sugar in your chili it cuts
the acidity of the tomatoes which Julian
hates and prefers everything to taste
like a raw tomato and lemon acidic as
hell and he's like does it need more
lemon and I'm like what is going on in
your mouth i person I mean I I do trust
though in your methods and I know that
like with sugar and this sort of thing
it makes it taste so much better so the
kind that I like to make well like play
off of is if you go on Pinterest and you
look up like a Wendy's copycat Joey
mm-hmm because I like how like sweet it
is yeah cuz I'm a child password
anyways here we go this is the
ingredients for the copycat Wendy's
chili you can link it to you want to
just link sure two pounds of ground beef
oh no oh no no no 129 ounce can of
tomato sauce that is that we got crushed
Tomatoes same thing one can of kidney
beans mm-hmm we got four boxes get on my
level one can of pinto beans not in this
chili not in this chili two fourteen
point five ounces of diced tomatoes mmm
I got one I got one
did you miss measure I'm just making
this up I don't know Karen that's fine
one yellow onion we don't have that nan
this chili no produce this is quarantine
in this chili beans and water pre bridge
the celery no not here [ __ ] we don't
need her one green bell pepper where is
she I don't know she didn't show up
cumin powder chili powder black pepper
salt sugar beef broth I don't know her
never heard of her what are we put in
first it's getting hot a little bit of
oil just so we can cook the garlic in
the pepper I can't see so oh my god this
is crazy I'm just doing enough to like
sort of coat the bottom cuz we this was
my nice like sauce pot and somehow we
decided that we were gonna make popcorn
in it like all the time and I just
started burning the box
yeah it really started like ravaging the
bottom so you do need you absolutely
need like a oil or something to cook in
this pan or else it'll burn on there
although it used to be nice and then we
bought a popcorn maker off Amazon and
holy crap that thing is amazing what $15
I don't know what
so I've already gotten more way more
than $15 worth out of that dude we we've
been cooking popcorn out of this pot for
like five years straight more problem
you like shake it shake it and we're
always like Oh see it's smoking
why why is it small it's on medium for
what do you want it on on a scale of one
to ten heat wise what do you want wait
why is it smoking babe what babe what
because we literally just discussed how
there's burned parts of this pot so it
smokes easier wait so do I need to cook
out of another pot you're fine just we
got to start adding things it's just
smoke then you're just smoke all right
let's just throw in however much garlic
we oh it's hot babe it's too hot what's
it on three minutes right away down
that's too much energy it was on it was
on three I'm serious no it's on the 2.5
one that is way too much energy all
right let that cook you don't have any
onion now we don't when you got chili
meat I got you
so general what's special about this
recipe absolutely nothing it's missing
all the ingredients that's special about
it
I'm hungry is what's special about it
why do you would burn and Scratchy on
the bottom if my chili burns because of
this pot I swear to not okay don't
preemptively cry no this thing it's
super hot huh like this it's a cooktop
you know what I want to look into
getting a quiet one because people are
like I use this for my videos and people
complain that it's loud but they also
complain that it kids like high-pitched
feedback so no I'm like all right I'm an
oppa nice yeah I'm the muscle in the
kitchen so you need a can opened you
hand me the can opener and I will open
that can we also made a delicious cuz we
don't have any cheese really that we
want to use on chili we're saving it for
a like a rainy day where you just really
need cheese we actually need it in chili
no actually like super live without it
obviously anyone can live without cheese
here is like a cashew cream that we made
out of cashews can I just say first of
all have you seen a cashew plant a tree
like how they grow it grows like a tree
right no no like they look like
goblins it looks like a goblins nose
coming out of this like bell pepper
thing it's so wild looking anyway I
think it's so special and cooled that
and I didn't know this until I started
you know eating plants and trying to get
creative with recipes but like I'm gonna
just keep this simple here okay if
you're at home right now and you've
never tried this I really think you
should put a handful of cashews roasted
salted raw whatever you have water and a
little bit of salt in a high-powered
blender makes a cream it makes a cream
and it does it happens in a minute and
you take it out and you turn it into
that you can use it you can season it to
be a sour cream you can make it more of
an alfredo nacho cheese it's incredible
it's like one of the coolest life hacks
that I've ever learned and I think
especially during a time like right now
if you want [ __ ] cheese or a cheesy
cream sauce do that just try it shoes it
is so cool dude really gets a lot easier
to find some cashews and cheese right
now yes correct
Thank You bunny is very interesting
what's going on over here why do you
wanna come to chili cook-off or what
she's being so cute so what's the order
what do we got next well I mean now's
when you would sort of throw in some
onions and you would definitely like
brown up your meat yeah but uh since we
ain't got that [ __ ]
why don't you put in the tomatoes yeah
and then I don't know I'm not really
just look at my midsection while I do
this I'm not really like measuring so
I'm just gonna see what it looks like
and diced tomatoes are in cool crushed
Tomatoes but those bouillon cube in
there boo Yong
does all that water we're gonna put
water in it and cook it so I don't
really care all right we are it's
vegetable flavored there we go
vegetables we're just putting everything
in the pot and going did you measure
that water no how much how much what
does it call for wat air how much water
to it like two cups
this is definitely not 200 let me see
did you even stir it this is like four
cups don't come in here without anything
then I'm with the energy what cube oh
you just want me to put it in you want
some chili you win some chili cook-off
can you open these yeah I got you so
Jenna yeah what is it about chili and
soup that you find so comforting and
necessary in your life I don't know we
just would eat it a lot so it's like a
childhood thing yeah well like I used to
eat a lot of soup because it was really
good and I don't know like so I remember
some days like I had a working mother
obviously and I would come home from
school and I'd be hungry and my mom
would always get me like little cans of
soup should I dream this right but in
there yeah right and I would have like a
little can of soup and I just thought
that that was like the most amazing food
and my dad used to make us that bean
soup that I love called thirty bean soup
like some outrageous number of bean soup
and also like a lot of my comfort foods
like a garbage plate is actually covered
in a chili like substance so you're just
a chilly out wait before you open that
last one I'm just wanna make sure is it
too much yeah just bringing him up here
in case of one of them all cuz we don't
have anything in the chili other than
beans which I'm totally down with I
could just eat I'm sorry this is like
gross y'all oh I lost it
I could just like eat beans non-stop I
think they're so tasty beans are good no
I know a lot of people are like beans
upset my stomach and I'm like well you
should try eating more beans and then
your body's like we get it now
well actually when I first met you I was
like well no I mean ever everyone reacts
to different foods differently honestly
there's no universal rule but when I
first met Jenna you were big into beans
as you are now and I always thought you
know I I don't I try to stay away from
people I love art it's all I love beans
I always thought that beans make you
fart even though like that really is
just kind of like I feel like an
experience from maybe a majority of
people that blue was blown out of
proportion a little bit because then
like you said I started eating more
beans because I was hanging out with you
and I started to be like oh my god these
are amazing and I'm not farting more
than normal yeah well sorry don't think
like about vegans or people that eat
beans all the time they're like oh you
just probably fart all the time and I'm
lame nah dude no I thought all the time
it's just as I want I feel like I don't
know if you don't eat beans and then all
of a sudden you eat some beans I could
understand that goes for anyway yeah
like cauliflower or broccoli or
something you know but like I don't know
I feel like you just get used to eating
beans all the time and it's like eating
any other food to me I don't know
yeah throw that in there the wind throw
that kidney bean ass in a circle yeah
okay I don't know what that anyways how
is this to listen to awful I'm so sorry
I have to have chili so honestly I think
it's it sounds much but we have the mics
like you're considering recording this
podcast in the kitchen and I was like
the audio I don't want to deal with that
so I was like can we just cook it in the
podcast room and here we are ourselves
alright a tablespoon of cumin so I'm
just gonna measure to that's my [ __ ]
right there we should have bought a
trash bag mmm trash bag all yay
I mean this this this stuff right here
this was recommended by our wonderful
neighbor who provided us peppers are you
ready feeling about this chili dog was I
downstairs or was I just not listening
anyway this is a quarter cup but I mean
none of the rest of what we've done has
followed any well it's chili powder
we're making chili we need a lot of it
yeah but we can always do that I'm so
what doesn't one dude yeah dude it's
gonna take way too long dude it's gonna
take too long and you know all right I'm
gonna start slow with this I'm gonna add
some water to this is that this is this
is the sugar and salt and black pepper
and then I can add more because I think
I added a little more sugar in there
then and then the agua there's water
yeah that's that's a lot of water just
saying it's more than you asked for I'm
just I I miss measured I'm just letting
you know
I'm trying to make jelly I know I know
you're trying to make chili oh oh I put
like a lot of chili powder in there
have you ever considered no I'm not I
don't what do I hate what do I hate tell
me what I hate whenever I'm making
something that requires like a bra he
hates when I put in like water like
enough to cook whatever we're cooking
because to him it looks watery because
you shouldn't watery like that it needs
to only have is when to liquid forever
in it for it to be done because it's
donal you have to let it cook out oh
it's done right now oh okay well you
know what the guy who the guy who
doesn't like to you know have patience
with his recipes and doesn't like to use
water
I fixed the curry that you messed up
last week so you're welcome Jenna made
some Jenna [ __ ] pulled some real Airy
[ __ ] and one morning not evening morning
she woke up and was like I'm making
curry so she got these soy curls got the
spices got the water turned into some
blonde whisked it together had like a
pseudo recipe up had some what even else
was it was like a coconut milk and she
started making this curry and I was like
dude I'm about it you know I'm not
really hungry right now because it's you
know 10 a.m. and I don't want curry but
I'll help you and then we made the whole
thing and we sat down and she took a
bite and she was like yeah this is
inedible this is so bad obviously we're
like struggling here like everyone else
you know in terms of like cooking normal
[ __ ] because we don't have the
ingredients we're not going to the store
we're just cooking out of our pantry but
so I fixed it I went back I add some
diced tomatoes
I'm spiced it up with a julienne you
know Aries flare and I turned it into
like kind of a mix between Thai and
Indian curry and we had some white rice
with it and it turned out Bom it did
turn out BOM it did turn our Bom would
you ever consider putting them maybe not
a website but like a list of your
recipes your favorite like garbage plate
and chili and your favorite comfort food
recipes on like a little blog cuz if you
wanted to you know where you could do
that you could do it on Squarespace
it is amazing it's actually tap no I
will filtered it Squarespace is an
amazing platform since you're asking
about it I did yes if you if maybe you
guys want to see Jenna's favorite
recipes and she's like you know what I
want to share my favorite recipes and
you know she's like I'll create a little
blog she could do it on Squarespace you
know you go to Squarespace it's a drag
and drop platform that is super easy to
build a beautiful website that looks
exactly and functions exactly how you
would like it to with pretty much zero
website experience at all you don't need
to know how to code you don't need any
of that if you ever run into any snags
while you're building a website on
Squarespace they have 24 hours a day 7
days a week customer support
award-winning customer support so if
you're stuck with something they're
there to help you get unstuck so that
you can make a beautiful beautiful
website right now you can do a free
trial on Squarespace calm or you go to
Squarespace comm slash Jenna Julianne
and you get an extra 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain you can
track who's looking at your website the
traffic and you can add online shops
there's so many ways to customize your
website just do it with Squarespace okay
it is a great platform also guys the
skin wake up to the skin over seven
million people currently wake up to the
news from the skin which is a really
great way to consume news I personally
love it
it's bite size it hits on the important
points of what's going on in the world
it's there's a huge amazing lack of
opinion it's just facts it's wonderful
it's great but if they do it in a
tasteful way it's not robotic either so
check it out go to th es que I am calm
/ - no Julian okay and type your email
hit subscribe and you're done it's easy
it's free it doesn't require anything
okay and then you wake up to a beautiful
concise helpful informative newsletter
in your inbox for you guys to consume
and then when you you know you go about
your day you're just more informed and
that can only lead to good things for
you
you're better off and you can contribute
better to the world when you're informed
do it with the skin also guys if you're
struggling to get some clothes in your
wardrobe or change it up or get some
style or maybe just refresh the old
wardrobe for a new season or event or
whatever it is you don't feel like going
shopping
are you don't feel like online shopping
and you're just stressed out by it go to
stitch fix it is an amazing service is
an online personal style styling service
that finds and delivers clothes for you
to you you fill out a little profile
with your style preferences of what you
like to wear what you don't like to wear
you know they'll show you a couple
pieces of clothing and you say yes I
would wear that no when were that and
they they sort of just kind of round you
out you know your style and then they
assign a personal stylist to you and
then they ship you a box of clothes
specifically curated and put together
for you and if you don't like some of it
you can send some of the back it's on
them no worries but if you do like it
you keep it it's yours forever and you
wear it and you look great and you know
your Instagram you know goes goes up a
little bit and you get more likes and
it's not guaranteed but try it out go to
stitch fix comm slash Jenna Julianne or
click link down below you can extra 25%
off when you keep everything in your box
that's stitch fixed comm slash Angela
thank you sponsors and thank you guys
for being patient how are we doing over
here I saw you turned up the heat while
I was reading sponsors what is your
favorite episode of the office the chili
cook-off it's when he comes in with the
Chilean spills it on the floor yeah why
is that your favorite why do you like
that so much because I never really
watch the office what I saw that scene
and I almost peed my pants he makes me
laugh so hard
did you who do we show that scene to for
the first time was he your mom recently
yes yes she wants it was like the first
time yeah maybe it was your mom I don't
know but yes it was your mom seeing her
reaction to that scene for the first
time was like she was so stressed out
she couldn't believe it it's like just
an iconic scene it is that's gonna be us
in 30 minutes walking down stairs with
this it's gonna be you cuz I already
told you I can't carry this down the
stairs without falling so you want to
know my role with Joey what's her rule
with chilli because there's no actual
meat in there like a no yours was so
like low and slow cook it for a long
laughs no no don't blast it fast but
like you know the meat starts to like
really flavor every what makes it taste
so good for sure it's like you know how
my dad cooks pasta sauce yes meat in it
and that's what actually makes the sauce
taste so good but I've never been able
to like honestly I've never been able to
let cook like our chili cook for more
than 30 No well it's because you're too
excited it tastes good [ __ ] it well I
mean there is it's so true like a lot of
recipes like pasta sauce or chili or
even like the PO Soleil that I made
those recipes call for you to cook those
things for hours and it's all because of
the meat
yeah and if you cut that part out you
technically don't need to do that yeah I
mean you'll lose out on the flavor but
maybe it's so delicious and I don't care
it's faster and it's faster so how do
you plan on incorporating the cashew
creme how do you just pour it in the big
pot or you will add it to your
individual bowl Oh usually like you
serve yourself a little bowl of chili
we'll have like we have little bowls
sitting you're like eating a chili and
then you just pour it anymore so you a
little as you want the waiter can come
over and you'll say when yeah I mean
usually when we have this you can have
like some green onion some cheese Oh
green onion oh this is really a she's
scallions are really really good do you
like bread with your chili you just
don't really care you just what you want
the chili
I just want chili that's fine I was like
the beans in the tomato I guess I was
really cold growing up you were called
growing up if you lived in a very very
cold environment you'll just be cold and
you need something to eat that's hot
well weirdly we're getting a lot of
chilly weather recently it's been
raining non-stop it's overcast like
every single day yeah and it definitely
increases like that's why we're making
like curry and stuff like it just makes
you want to eat that food no kidney
beans so no I do so now you're subjected
to my [ __ ] I'm always subjected to
your [ __ ]
like every day I am I did ask for it I
wouldn't want it any other way
Hey so you could cover this but since
I'm like a quick chili cooker I'm like
nah you just how's it looking guys the
Kelly girl this literally just beans and
tomato and chili that looks like it's
not really cooking catch I tried to turn
it up turn up turn up [ __ ] turn up out
it was spicy it's still way too tomatoey
Julianne I don't think that's safe where
else are you gonna put it Julianne I
don't what if that's not safe and dude
why are you doing that to my pot well
this pots [ __ ] you already burned it now
you're gonna like lacerate the side with
the can opener
please rip pot who's screaming probably
Kermit I put okay when I came back up
here with the water I put your kissing
booth which we still have and another
giant box at the bottom of the stairs in
hopes that it would barricade them from
coming to the door they got to get the
door I think it worked
and so shouts out to your kissing booth
dude I love outsmarting those little
guys yeah oh yeah it does come on how
does it not make you feel good when you
outsmart them no no it is us versus them
I feel bad we're outnumbered we are
that's something like it feels good I
just pulled a three for three on one
here I did a 1v3 okay I blocked all
three of them off the stairs feels good
i won i won did you dunk on anyone I
dumped on Kermit specifically there you
go home and cry how does he get dunked
on you don't have to go that hard yeah
you know I did I need more caffeine I
feel crazy yeah I feel like it never
woke up today I just woke up and it was
like where are my beans where my being
you don't carry some y'all you should
make a music video about chili
absolutely not
yes you should and you're like rapping
in front of the green screen but this
just beans falling from the sky my god
this I think this is the first time I've
ever had a chili that's just tomatoes
and beans know you've had veggies Oh
instead of like no veggies like nothing
no onion well this is how this is how I
will make pad thai sometimes like with
just the noodles the sauce and tofu and
you hate it because you're like oh
there's no vegetables is terrible
nothing and like that's how I cook it
when I'm able to go to the store and
corentin´s not happening like that's how
I cook it you just cut out all the
unnecessary business I mean if I'm
really trying to go for Flair or if I'm
filming it or fight friends over and I'm
cooking for people yeah I'll throw in
some veggies I'll make it more you know
finessed but when I'm just like
sometimes dude you know what I've
learned about myself sometimes when I
get really drunk my drunk thing to do is
go to the kitchen turn on the wok and
make five minute pad thai like I'm
talking I make it so fast it's like fast
and dirty but it's literally oil noodles
something in this for like two seconds
throw them in the pot get some tofu in
there stir it up sometimes I don't even
have time for the tofu because I'm just
like so drunk and hungry I [ __ ] whip
the thing up together the sauce is
everywhere it's oily it's great and I
eat it and it is just like it's nirvana
it is so good and it doesn't have
anything besides like three ingredients
so there is something to be said about
keeping it simple I'm just gonna say
that and it pays off at a time like this
and we don't have ingredients true I
feel like my drunk food has always been
a can of soup that's so tame it's so
good I need I need fire I knew like
grilled cheese or you've seen me make
grilled cheese drunk grilled cheeses for
like a group of people before he brings
out like a cutting board of like 20
grilled cheeses for everybody and I'm
like what how did you oh my god
I'm not even gonna ask how did you make
that many grilled cheeses so fast yeah I
feel like a fully operating kitchen call
me a kitchen please sama kitchen
cafeteria man if I owned a restaurant I
would hire people and train them to only
cook exactly like I cook there would
just be a bunch of Julien's every eight
years
but imagine our service record it's
dangerous dangerous okay we would have
an on-site doctor he's like screaming
down there here there's like he's doing
that super alert Bart's character
building he's fine
you understand that me and karma are
like never away from each other so no I
quite literally understand that and when
it when you are away from each other he
spontaneously combusts into tears how's
it tasting what was okay mana Homer said
sold on this chilly powder yet do you
need more of it you need a different
chili powder you think taste it
but it need way to tomatoey yeah cuz it
hasn't cooked at all Oh wanting to be
ready no we got a cookie babe I think it
needs a little more chili powder
actually yeah a little more salt and
sugar soldier see that's not me to go
get some and I'll say hi to crime
yeah if you want I'll talk about soldier
do we need any more water you hate that
huh
okay tell me what I'm getting chili
powder different chili powder oh and
that's soldier soldier nothing else all
right
BRB time me all right try to get your
best time hurry up and go oh can you get
my gloves the gloves on the door okay
soldier is half sugar half salt its
origin lies in the hit NBC comedy Parks
and Recreation where I think Leslie
Knope of the parks department and City
City Council is prevented from doing
work she's on leave and so she needs to
do something with her time so she
invents solder which has salt and sugar
mixed together and I love that invention
and I personally actually want to invest
into a container in my kitchen similar
to a salt container and a sugar
container but a soldier container and I
want to have her face on it because it
isn't important I feel like it's an
important thing to have in your house
makes pre-mixed together I use it for a
lot of things like in the show she
talked about putting it on butterscotch
pudding I think and I feel like that
would be pretty good I've never had that
before but I don't doubt that it would
be good another important thing that I
would use soldier for regularly is sushi
rice which I make all the time
I make sushi rice like more than anyone
should be making sushi rice because I
don't even really eat sushi that much
but like I just love the flavor of sushi
rice and in sushi rice you know you cook
the rice short grain white
and then when it's done cooking you
season it in salt sugar and rice vinegar
and I would love if I didn't have to go
to two containers one to the salt and
then next over to the sugar to get that
prepared I would love to just get a
spoon and go straight for the soldier I
don't know I think solar is just one of
those ingredients that people don't
really appreciate because they don't
know about it and then when they hear
about it they think it's silly or niche
but it's not it's it's a difference
maker it's one of those things that and
the future people will have soldier
containers in their house I think and
that's what it's all about I don't know
where Genna went I don't think she's
coming back
you guys want some chili it's actually
looking pretty good oh it just splashed
everywhere splashed okay I'm not gonna
touch it anymore it just flashed on my
arm and on our keyboard everything's
great though no I was saying it I was
like I can't wait til summer when you
jump in the pool and then splashed
everywhere it does smell good in here
all right oh yeah where'd you get two
types the chili powder Oh Oh dried
poblano ancho yeah yeah yeah yeah a
little more depth look at that look at
yes it's so deep here's some other type
of chili powder
ooh I like the other type and there's
more your soldier with a little black
pepper I love me some soldier add too
much add too much add too much did you
say how did the rat yeah he's fine he's
just standing his upon him who stares
like scream barking OH
cue go rat we never like forbid him from
going somewhere that he wants to go so
yeah he's having a heart yeah he's a
spoiled little rat he's having trouble
with the rules I didn't know I didn't
know you're just watching it didn't I
didn't touch it though when I'm cooking
I just taste so like 800 times the whole
time I want it already that's how I cook
too
mmm yummy yummy in your tummy a squad
yeah yeah it's still cooking though you
need to cook a little more I would eat
it whenever I do not care
well no I mean you're you're always when
preaching that and you need to cook the
tomato eat miss out of it so let's get
there to be honest with you
I'll probably have a little bit now to
eat it cuz I want some but then yeah I'd
probably cook it a little longer okay
so we'll have some for the podcast enjoy
it a little sample taster our gloves oh
it's fine I could no Julian the whole
pots gonna be hot you're gonna have to
let it sit here and cool off me I want
Julian oh my god it's really not hard I
went to like I think it was middle
school with a kid that sometimes would
just sit at his desk and see how long he
could like hold his breath and like his
face returned really red do you know my
brother one time put his hand he was
very young on the oven door and when it
was on like this he's mine
oh my god and then he started screaming
oh my god and he would not take it off
yeah you know he didn't understand yeah
but that was that's what was causing
your pain it was so ridiculous and my
mom was like take your it's like
electrocuting is that what a dumb dumb
kids are dumb kids be like I'm stupid
good one
Thanks are you excited to have some
chili yes serve me serve me chili it's
like it's not really ready but well you
know what for the for the sake of the
podcast we have to try some so why don't
we share a little Bowl okay
let's share a little baby ball and you
have to put it in this bowl though okay
all right I'm scared make sure you stir
it though yeah be careful okay oh I'll
be as careful
[Music]
Julian this is the wrong spoon how's it
look looks good little watery you think
everything is watery did you know that
there's different types of chili it
doesn't have to be like as thick as
oatmeal oh I've has to be thicker than a
bolo meal all right so you wanna shall
we move that spoon out of there
pour the crema this is the cashew cream
oh by the way why do you have to sniff
it like that
they got up they got up the stairs here
that look like they finally broke
through the barricade oh so he go I
can't really tip it that much farther
without spilling it everywhere it looks
good need some chili yeah it looks good
here's the spoon for you and it's been
for you there's two why don't you move
some of that I'm so excited for chili
doing the cashew crema in like that
makes me hello let's go yeah yeah
definitely cook down a little more yeah
but it's still gonna taste good because
it's your chili and you're a good chef
and you're wonderful and cute mmm yeah
it needs to like cook more of the tomato
out mmm but that's really good though
exactly what I want
it's like pockets surprisingly good in
terms of like the flavor mm-hmm with no
veggies or meat
I usually will put either like beyond
ground beef or beyond sausage some sort
of like meat subsidy when the kidney
beans hit dude they'd be hidden well
it's so good I just need beans I just
want some candy beans I spelled down my
pants
there's no card game cast just eaten
beans better what why do you have to
slip it like that like what let me try
it again
this is how I eat normally I
that's normal that's how you that's how
you take a bite of a spoon no when he's
cooking he'll take the spoon and like
put the whole really like oh it needs
more salt or whatever that's not women
and then when you try and get me to
taste something I'll taste like just the
end of this because I'm just trying to
taste it you're like no no have more no
that's not true what I'm doing is I'm
trying to make it so you can actually
get an accurate taste of what I'm
cooking I'm not trying to make it teach
you gonna teacher your eating habits
someone who's scratching in the door
like someone made it one of the minute
of its the Hunger Games I think
Kermit you think I think it's Beach she
could jump over that yeah but she
doesn't want to come up here she does
permit no no no okay she wants to Kermit
Kermit needs to get up here like he's a
fish and this is water he will die if he
doesn't come up here in his mind bunny
you're just laughing at them fools
you're like yeah I'd behave myself so I
don't have to wait down on the bottom of
stairs you see who's here who's behind
door number one yeah let's guess I think
it's peach I think it's Kermit I think
peach is downstairs I think it's Kermit
and I think he's crying and I think he's
alone - oh these beans Oh baby it let me
check who's behind door number one no
that's not true
leave the door open for one second I
want to see who's up here yeah when get
absolutely wrecked it was me I know oh
it's cuz she's the most athletic she
probably just jumped the barricade thank
you for providing Chile I'm excited to
eat a big bowl of this in a little bit
right yeah hello I mean it just beans
but sometimes you just need a better
vehicle for you beans you could also put
it on something I used to make chili
tolds for breakfast all the time yeah
you did just make it like a quick little
Chili's out of some beans and tomato and
chili powder and throw it on a piece of
toast it's amazing yeah the beans be
hitting more for me well I guess that's
it next week
we're bringing the wok up here oh my god
and I'm cooking pad thai on the podcast
very very aggressively Marin is like I
needed being so bad that is so good is
it hitting that spot for you good I'm
glad thank you you're welcome
thank you thank you for understanding
that I'm just like a a person that needs
soup and chili and Buffalo things
suddenly I understand to keep moving I
get it yeah thank you for understanding
that I would rather eat sushi rice then
literally anything else all the time
just sushi right yeah
okay that's fine have you ever put
chilli in sushi rice okay don't tarnish
YUM the good things in life what if you
took a roll of sushi but sushi rice put
it chili in it memories about come on
your mouth is not right chili sushi no
we're not what we're not gonna do is say
chili sushi juicy okay cut everybody
back to one reset take it from the top
thanks for coming to my chili cook-off I
hope you guys are making some good food
while you're at home and oh what you
have and yeah it was what I really
wanted and I'm really happy
good I'm gonna let this cook for a
little while we're gonna eat the rest of
it yeah I'm gonna eat the rest of ya I
think you'll have one bowl and then move
on but not me that's a lot I'm gonna
need that whole pot over the next few
days move on to the pad thai no no I'm
gonna eat that whole pot good we got to
make food that we can sustain you know
it's gotta last anyway thank you guys
for listening thank you for hanging out
this is not just a podcast but an
experience and that is what we aim to
provide kinda turn it up turn up it rank
it we'll see you guys next week for
another podcast and we'll see you all
week on twitch thank you guys for
hanging we love you and we hope you're
happy healthy and well good bye
[Music]